your speed dating continues with me I'm
going to start with congratulations
uh uh you guys did great
um I like throwing a curveball before I
get started into the movie uh for both
of you if someone has actually never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why
I don't think that person exists for me
I mean
um I'm gonna go with this and the reason
why is because it's the most current
thing I've done and I want to continue
growing you just you don't understand
what I'm saying like this is what I'm
doing right now or just did right now so
that's as close to who I am as I can
show you on film right now yeah I'd like
to steal that answer but just to switch
just to switch up I'm going to go
opposite end of that and say the first
thing I ever did which was play fizzy in
Bugsy Malone on stage and I I don't know
that I've topped it
wow uh thank you for that um one of the
things that I love about this film is
that it doesn't try to hollywoodize the
story it's a real honest depiction of
two people and their relationships and
the ups and downs can you sort of talk
about that aspect of it
yeah I think for both of us uh that was
a major reason this was so intriguing to
do and a reason to want to be a part of
it was that it did depict uh not just a
gay relationship but a relationship in
general through
perhaps more highs and lows than one is
expecting to see in a film but one
should for sure expect in real life
um and that was that was very satisfying
to get to to play that many different
temperatures and variations of what they
were going through yeah I think um
Michael Showalter said to me quite early
on he said what do you want to and it
was an interesting question he was like
what do you want to do with this like
part what do you want to achieve with it
and I'd my answer was that I just wanted
to be believed and I think that goes for
the movie as well that I just I just
wanted to I want the movie to be
believable and in that way I think you
have to like offer the full spectrum of
something and I think it shows the full
spectrum of a relationship and not just
the rose tinted version of it or not
just the tragic version of it and I
think that's something that we're both
really proud of in it and I hope that's
playing really well in the film is that
it really is it really is the the what
it is to be in a relationship for a long
time and the journeys that you the
journey that you go on with that
Michael's on said a lot I or I think
every day and what was it like actually
having him there watching because as a
performer there's you know you want to I
would like to think you want to create
some sort of distance to make the
character your own but you're making it
that's really these are real people can
you sort of talk about that Dynamic
Michael Osceola was actually pretty
vocal in his uh stating that he
understood that what we were doing was
not going to mimic his real life and
that he or mirror it completely and that
this was its own creature like he said
that many different times and in many
different ways and which is not to say
that all of the pressure is taken away
by knowing that the source of the source
material is there the whole time but
most of it is and and we've talked this
has come up a couple of times but like
we both drew a lot of
um strength I think and power from just
being able to see him there and know
that he was there really centering our
performances and just the journey we're
going on there was the man who would
lived it you know right there I always
find it funny watching Club scenes and
movies because I know everyone in those
scenes it has to be super quiet there's
no music actually playing you're trying
to dance and you're trying to make it
believable but it's as fake as it can be
can you sort of talk about
um filming those like a scene like that
so they are they are very strange yeah
scenes to film and I think like there
are also scenes that I that like you do
watch all the time and and you're aware
of that or like you're aware of the
background artists a lot and um this I
found this is this was fun to do but it
was funny to do yeah as well yeah uh
because yeah there is no music and
you're bopping to to nothing bopping
I'll tell you this too we also we shot
this it was about a year ago almost to
the day that we probably shot that scene
right now and so we were that a year ago
in covid so it was especially odd to be
mimicking kind of a hot and sweaty gay
dance club type vibe in that era it was
like it felt felt extra dirty it was it
was actually dead for both of you uh
when I'm assuming when you were looking
at the script and you saw the schedule
there must have been a dare to circled
on the calendar that you're like these
are going to be really tough days and
these are the days where I really you
know what I mean what were those what
was the day or two that you had circled
on the calendar that you're not nervous
about but you know we're really thinking
about
the first day we worked together yeah
the first ever day was we shot all of
the oncology appointments so like the
diagnosis and the trips back to the diet
to the doctor to get about the radiation
I mean
finding out there was terminal yeah like
yeah so we we couldn't have been uh we
had never acted together before
literally yeah so day so day one was
circled and I think that meant the rest
of it I didn't I didn't Circle any of
the rest of them because that was like
we stopped it was a baptism of fire we
duck yeah we Dove right into the deep
end day one and it just continued from
there it all felt it all felt momentous
and all felt special the them falling in
love felt equally as important you know
and important to get right so it just
kind of set the tone uh yeah where we
carried on when you're looking at a
script and you're getting ready to shoot
do you like preparing everything before
the shoot begins
um as an actor or are you sort of like
preparing certain things how does it
actually work before you step on set for
each of you I think what I wanted to do
was get to know kids and get to know my
version of Kit and get to know the
source material as well as I could in
the time that I had and to fill to feel
like I had a really good handle on them
and it and my instinct for it and then I
think like in terms of preparing stuff
yes learning the lines but I I never
have I made this maybe as a kid or a bad
thing never have I made less decisions
about how I would play something out and
I loved that that I came to a scene and
I was never sure what Jim was going to
do I was never fully sure of what I was
gonna do and it was kind of just
trusting we're just you know very
accurate thing to say but there was a
distrust between us to find our own way
and also like as much as all you want to
ever achieve as an actor is to react in
the moment that's that's when you when
you're in the moment is when it's at its
best I think and I and I and I feel like
I try to allow myself to to do that more
than ever before yeah I think every
project is obviously unique and specific
in its own ways and this one very much
was of the term Ben just said I feel
like the biggest amount of work I did I
obviously read the book several times
and referenced it a lot for myself and
in that tone just kind of tracking in
pin little points of the way Michael's
Journey need to meeting kit falling in
love with kid meeting kids parents a
cancer diagnosis you know reliving the
trauma of his mother like those were
like the highlights but everything else
was really the meat was put on those
bones every day when we went in there
yeah and also we never stopped
discussing them as well as people I
think that was that was never ending
between us and Michael Walters we would
have zooms to still talk about that
coming that week yeah that was really
exciting actually I mean you really was
a very collaborative process in that way
and very gratifying at the time on that
note again I just want to say congrats
and um have a fantastic day thank you
for your time thank you thank you